oui c'est l'interview pop star
mais j'ai arrêté un peu start et devant
un jury de professionnels composé nous
quatre et on sait pas si on va te faire
chanter ta première chanson bonjour vous
appelez comment tu m'appelles gérard
darmon gérard darmon vous avez quel âge
est rare beaucoup déjà oui n'est pas
vraiment un débutant 84,24 ça va est ce
que vous pensez trachéotomie g1 est ce
que vous pensez avoir les qualités pour
faire un bon chanteur
ah oui complètement oui complètement je
sais j'ai complètement oui oui ça
complètement c'est bien sert à fait
confiance en vous moi j'ai une confiance
a complete totale en moins sur deux
moules à jovial et la gnac gérard oui
oui je vais vous irez loin sert à faire
la première partie tout de suite billy
crawford s'est pas arrivé c'était trop
d'un coup j'ai sérieusement la chanson
vous faites ça en amateur où vous êtes
prêt à tout lâcher pour réussir
moi je suis prêt je suis prêt vraiment
je le dis très sérieusement à tout
lâcher pour hull à sheffield chergui ce
costume marron par exemple si vous me
demandez ça mais ça sera peut-être un
petit peu obligatoire il va charrier ce
polo marron cette chemise marron aussi
wii et ses chaussures marron alors que
ses chaussettes mans font les frais
aussi pour les fringues et la famille
la popstar la pop star ce soir oui oui
absolument
les franges les retours mais je lui ai
dit moi j'irai
est ce que vous croyez en vous et
inversement
inversement surtout vous aimez chanter
quoi font petit j'ai pas je sentais une
chanson que je n'ai pas prise mais mais
je vais essayer de la faire quand même
là maintenant elle s'appelle là
maintenant allez je vous écoute mais
ligne turbo des micros marc gène gérard
qui va nous faire là maintenant c'est
lors du recul à la maintenant là
maintenant là maintenant
maintenant il ya encore du travail alors
on en revient que c'est formidable bond
à bohain des chanteurs de qualité à la
télévision vesti a du pognon sur les sms
laurent gerra par d'euros mon petit
gérard si tu veux après lui après son
petit jeu au niveau au niveau
d'interprétation bon oui j'suis pas
encore complètement ça vous vous en
rendrez compte assez bien pour ça je
suis myope star parce que je compte
beaucoup ri est-ce qu'il faut savoir des
professeurs pour vous oui vous avez
raison
est-ce que c'est déjà fait l'acteur ça
vous aiderai l'actorat je dis pas qu
après avoir fait une carrière de
chanteur je ferai pas l'acteur la voix
faut essayer un petit peu dans les aigus
là vous êtes un petit peu trop dans les
six ou
il a du mal dans les aigus je sais pas
si bons au niveau look alors ça va les
chemins vous n'êtes pas faire une
couleur non alors il est prêt à tout et
si on vous dit banco pour le maintien en
février mon effigie on me dit quoi c'est
de la folie
vous seriez mais je suis prêt à faire le
saut et non oui ah bon mais bien sûr est
ce que vous seriez prêt à chanter ça
ce dépôt
encore
et ça amène du monde mourra pas la même
des sentiments est à voir à quoi ça va
qu'est ce qu'ils approuvaient sinatra
dans la chanson se vendront chose c'est
bien